foreign
up the biggest moments of 2022 for one
of Hollywood's most famous families I
hate talking about myself but how
Kanye's controversy is impacting his
co-parenting relationship with Kim I do
have you know a family that I have to
just be positive and get it together for
plus the backlash get your ass up and
work the cheating scandals this was
just really unforgivable in my books and
the major life events we knew that Elvis
had to marry us I am so grateful I just
keep reminding myself I made a beautiful
healthy boy plus an ET exclusive with
the momager who's kept us riveted for 15
years on reality TV let me tell you
something it does take a village yeah a
special Kardashian recap episode of ETS
the download starts right now
begin with the end of April
a marriage after nearly two years in
court Kim and Kanye settled their
divorce but not before things took a
nasty turn playing out in the public eye
we having the best divorce ever if we go
to court we'll go to court together
according to Court docs obtained by E.T
Kanye is handing over two hundred
thousand dollars a month in child
support he's also responsible for half
of their four children school and
Security expenses it's been a fight for
when my kids go to school and we started
our own School Kanye and Kim are sharing
joint custody of the kids with equal
access but Kim will still have the kids
the majority of the time there's no such
thing as 50 50 custody with with in
society today it always leans towards
the mom and that is sad to me and that's
not what I want
[Music]
according to their prenup they waived
any spousal support and division of
assets but gay is reportedly giving Kim
the 4.5 million dollar home he bought
near her 60 million dollar mansion
outside of L.A that's what's the house
next door what you think the point of
really being rich for a source tells E.T
Kim has relieved the divorce was
finalized adding she is Contin to focus
on her kids and their happiness we do
have
you know a family that I have to just be
positive and get it together for during
the contentious divorce and custody
battle yay made many public jobs
including accusing Kim of not allowing
him to see his kids wait when I pick him
up I feel like they borrowed a win I
gotta return I'm scan them like a
barcode Kanye is coming out with a new
rap song what does that mean that means
he's talking mad about me and probably
saying
whatever I tried everything humanly
possible to make a situation work now a
source tells E.T Kim is doing her best
to co-parent with him in a safe way at
the end of the day I just want my kids
to be happy and healthy and think the
world of their dad and they do this is
the mother of my children
and I apologize for any stress that I
have caused and Kanye couldn't help but
weigh in on his ex's relationship with
Pete Davidson Pete is has got to be
literally the best human being I've ever
met like the best heart when Kim and
Pete called it quits in August after
nine months of dating Kanye reacted in
the most Kanye way possible with a now
deleted Instagram post of a fake
headline reading skeet Davidson dead at
age 28. God sent me from that crash just
so I could beat Pete Davidson's ass A
source told E.T Pete sought trauma
therapy after the breakup in large part
due to Kanye's constant threats and
public attacks now Are You Gonna Kiss Me
Or Not I sure am Jasmine
foreign
romance played out across social media
but our sources blamed the breakup on
their busy schedules telling E.T in
short the spark between them faded I
wasn't even thinking like oh my God I'm
gonna be in a relationship with him I
was just thinking like
heard about this bde and there's no bad
blood our Insider says the X's still
keep in touch
he's just super genuine and it's just
really fun to just
hang out and do nothing for his part
Pete is moving on and things are heating
up with model Emily radakowski he seems
super Charming he's vulnerable he's
lovely
but let's rewind two happier times shall
we like when Kim and Pete made one of
their first big public appearances
together at the Met Gala in May for Kim
it was the culmination of her Blonde
Ambition to Channel A Hollywood icon
[Music]
I tried it on it didn't fit me and so I
looked at them and I said give me like
three weeks and I I had to lose 16
pounds
no sugar no carbs two a day workouts in
a sauna suit plus a 30 hour die job it
feels like
a movie role you know I'm determined how
are you feeling
initial dress tonight Kim
[Music]
where when Kim finally slipped into the
4.8 million dollar dress loaned to her
by Ripley's Believe it or not I had to
try the Prototype first it wouldn't even
go up over my hips and I just was like
devastated so she began transformation I
can't believe I did it like I just can't
believe it but Kim's Victory didn't come
without controversy critics slammed her
for ruining a relic but it turns out
this damage was done long before she
touched the Gown oh my gosh
actress Lily Reinhardt had a bigger
problem with Kim's rapid weight loss
I'll always be willing to talk about the
subjects that a lot of people maybe are
too afraid to do so the actress rip
Kim's extreme diet saying to walk on a
red carpet and do an interview where you
say how starving you are so wrong it
actually taught me a lot about my
lifestyle and my health Kim maintains
there was no starving but she did stick
to a strict diet of protein and veggies
cut out so much sugar a lot of junk food
I was eating I didn't even realize that
a lot of fried foods and I just
completely changed my lifestyle
but the backlash didn't end there
remember these Infamous words I have the
best advice for women in business get
your ass up and work that interview for
variety in March backfired big time if
you put in the work you will see results
it's that simple hi honey how are you
doing I don't know I'm assuming you saw
all of the backlash seven months later
we got a sneak peek at the turmoil it
caused behind the scenes I'm like
mortified wasn't a blanket statement
towards women or to feel like
I don't respect the work or think that
they don't work hard I know that they do
I'm so sorry I think people would assume
that I got everything handed to me but
being on a reality show let alone a
reality show girl with a sex tape does
not open doors and so I always felt like
I had to work extra hard and harder to
be taken seriously so my advice would be
go for it
as Celine Dion says shall we go for it
yeah we shall all right well Kim's
crisis team worked overtime her younger
sister Chloe finally opened up about
some serious baby daddy drama there was
just something I wasn't ready
to talk about
he always knew when the other baby was
being born
why would I want to have a baby with
someone who's having a baby with
somebody else I'm a lunatic but not like
that
deranged Tristan Thompson gave us the
Kardashian bombshell of the year when
news broke that he had fathered a child
with personal trainer Marilee Nichols at
the same time he was planning a second
baby with Chloe this isn't the biggest
sign for you to not have another baby
with this human being and here's the
real shocker baby number two was
conceived via surrogate just weeks
before Tristan's Affair was exposed and
he and merrily welcomed their son it was
definitely very angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled but wait there's more as
Tristan's Web of Lies unraveled We also
learned that he and Chloe got secretly
engaged after she turned down his first
proposal in 2020. I said you know I'm
not comfortable accepting this right now
because I'm not excited to tell my
family A source told EET in September
that Chloe said yes in February of 2021
which explains this rock that set social
media on fire around the same time but
the very next month Tristan allegedly
got merrily pregnant when we're in the
peak of our relationship you go ahead
and cheat on me God for like I don't
even want to know what you do in the
worst of our relationship
but in true Chloe fashion she's making
the best of a bad situation just own
whatever it is she welcomed her baby boy
in July and in September we watched her
become a mom of two after Tristan's
betrayal
[Music]
I am so grateful it's such a beautiful
gift that we're able to have it's
supposed to be a really exciting time
and it's just a different experience I
just feel bad for her
that
it the joy was kind of sucked out of it
again you know I never thought I would
have only one child another one would
just add more love to the house despite
all of the drama a source tells E.T the
X's are cordial and want to be the best
parents but they don't speak unless
they're co-parenting I think everyone
has to handle their co-parenting
situation in their own style for now
Chloe plans to have the baby full time
and wants Tristan in both of the kids
lives as much as he wants to be he's a
really Hands-On Dad we get along really
really well
[Music]
2022 also doubled the parenting fun for
Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott I feel
like with my second you just like
anticipate everything and you know
what's gonna happen I feel like I was a
lot more present
this time
I love it their second child a baby boy
arrived in February and Kylie admits to
fans it took some time to adjust it's
been really hard for me have some
anxiety well I cried non-stop all day
for the first three weeks this
experience for me personally has been a
little harder than with my daughter I
just keep reminding myself I made a
whole human beautiful healthy boy
[Music]
but Kylie Got Her Groove Back by April
at the Kardashians Premiere it was her
first red carpet appearance after baby
stormy excited to be a big sister
she is very excited to be a big sister
of stormy's little bro was initially
named wolf Webster that quickly changed
to something their parents felt was a
better fit but it is still under wraps
we haven't officially changed we have
some placeholders so before I officially
change it I just want to be sure
another car generous cyst with babies on
the brain Courtney she and new hubby
Travis Barker detailed their fertility
Journey on the Kardashians just before
their surprise marriage in Sin City and
that is where the couple tied the notch
for the first time in April just hours
after the Grammy Awards
[Music]
what were they wearing the same outfits
they had on afterwards show they said
vows
um Elvis officiated them they probably
kissed all we have to do I didn't
remember I had a bouquet I did throw up
after though and took my top off and
unbuttoned my pants Courtney said I do
again in Italy a few weeks later in this
custom Dolce and gamana white mini dress
at the seaside Portofino estate of the
famous designers
[Music]
kravis went on to buy their first home
together in October a 14.5 million
dollar beach house in Santa Barbara
where Travis originally popped the
question
[Music]
back then not everyone was on board we
got engaged look at mom got a ring
foreign
[Music]
but eventually Court's kids came around
and even played a part in the wedding as
for courts X Scott Disick well he's
staying drama-free as they co-parent
their three children our source told ET
in October Scott is more used to
Courtney and Travis's relationship now
and that Scott and Travis get along fine
as hard as it is it does give me a place
to like finally be able to move on
um the photos from that wedding stunning
absolutely but other snaps from 2022
captivated internet sluice across the
globe
[Music]
a photo feel so bad you don't know
whether to laugh or cry so Chloe did
both with Emojis when the sisters got
busted for this phony pic of true at
Disneyland the whole mess started when
Kim shared a snap of her daughter
Chicago and Chloe's daughter true at
Disneyland fans long suspected the snap
was altered and it turns out they were
right the Sham was revealed months later
when Chloe accidentally posted this a
video of Chu's actual first trip to the
happiest place on Earth this is true's
first time to Disneyland the camera that
work going on it's a small world
look at the camera
I sent it to Kylie for approval she goes
no I respect it so I photoshopped true's
face onto the stormy's body Photoshop
fail but what a major in September Kim
was accused of photoshopping her wait
for it neck reality star Spencer Pratt
couldn't help but chime in who needs
that muscle supporting your neck it's
just I guess it's a stupid muscle
Chris has been called out too Chef
Gordon Ramsay shared this picture with
the famous momager but it looked totally
different when she reposted it you're so
funny and in January fans were
scratching their heads over Chloe's
terrifyingly long hands when she was
accused of being ashamed of them she
responded LOL never my hands are
beautiful baby how do you deal with the
haters they say like you're changing
your photos things are fake you just
have to deal with it it is what it is I
don't take it too seriously
all right now too when things got real
serious when the family found themselves
in the crosshairs of Rob Kardashian's ex
you've been through a lot with the
Kardashians how is your relationship
with the family I mean I'm good yeah
yeah for sure but in April all eyes were
on their 10-day battle inside a federal
courtroom in La we also have this trial
blooming over our head Blac Chyna is
suing myself
Chloe Kylie and Kim China made some
explosive accusations demanding the
family pay her over 100 million dollars
for defamation of character and
interference of contract
as a mom I'm very protective of my kids
and it's really draining to be going
through this
he claimed the family scheme to have her
Rob and China reality TV show on E
canceled as revenge for their breakup
for the fact that you kept accusing me
of doing you're the one actually texting
females Rob
[Music]
but the family's attorney argued it was
China who damaged her own brand with bad
behavior which included a blowout fight
with Rob in 2016 where China admitted to
wrapping a phone cord around his neck
Kylie even testified China threatened to
kill her brother which China denied the
verdict arrived after just a day of
deliberations how are you doing I'm
doing good I'm doing good I'm uh just
feeling blessed right now leaving our
fate in the hands of 12 random people
what if they hate us turns out the jury
handed the Kardashians a major victory
and decided Blac Chyna wouldn't be
awarded a dime
number one
wait shut up what happened we won
the family got the news in New York as
they were getting ready for the Met Gala
congratulations we just received the
news about today I'm just
Blac Chyna claims she'll appeal and the
Kardashians have requested trying to
cover their 390
000 legal bill but as the battle rages
on in the courts Rob and China put their
differences aside to celebrate a big
milestone for their daughter dream when
she started kindergarten last fall a
source tells E.T Rob is Hands-On when it
comes to being a dad and prioritizing
dream so what's the latest Jeff living
life one month earlier dream teamed up
with Grandma Chris AKA Levy for her
first commercial you're doing an amazing
sweetie yep the Kardashians kids know
exactly how to steal the spotlight I'm
hearing kids can you stop this is like
your first time at work with me your
kids so I know I've been MIA for a while
[Music]
last year Northwest served us High
fashion and hilarious sass when she took
Paris Fashion Week by storm
and we saw Dorothy and her cousins take
a ticket
right now Tick Tock
Penelope Disick may love social media
but one thing she's definitely not a fan
of Mom no kissing
just one no sorry but it's all love when
the Kardashian Clan comes together to
celebrate oh my gosh true is turning
poor from big birthday bashes
North's creepy Wilderness birthday to
Spooky celebrations
[Music]
every party
look at this
this is insane so cute was guaranteed to
be over the top
hey dear true
happy birthday to you
I mean no one knows how to throw a party
better than Kris Jenner okay still ahead
and look at the momminger's best moments
of 2022.
you are my my you're my son mother's son
I'm your daughter no yeah I think we
should have taken my mom home when she
started playing peekaboo
oh so good all right plus Chris joins
E.T for an exclusive sit down
celebrating her family's 15 years of
reality TV anything you change along the
way it might looked back I'd need
another Martini
eat cheese the download we'll be right
back
[Music]
smells like a crazy party in here at
732. today oh my God this is an
expensive little trip we're on
yeah I think we should have taken my mom
home when she started playing peekaboo
[Music]
how's your birthday
my birthday is
fabulous you're my son my son I'm your
daughter
[Music]
here's the thing
I have a condo and I kind of forgot it
was there that sounds ridiculous doesn't
it can't wait to be wealthy enough to
forget I have property somewhere
[Music]
Guess who's coming over for lunch today
Martha Stewart let me know I want to buy
you for a housewarming gift a peacock
I have never said I wanted a peacock
before and then you know come on come on
come on
oh
[Music]
I love her Chris really did bring plenty
of last for us this year her family also
celebrated 15 years on reality TV she
sat down exclusively with ETS Michelle
Turner to talk about the Milestone could
you have dreamed this I mean you could
you could be handed every opportunity in
the world and unless you have the exact
perfect dream team in place to execute
what it is that has been handed to you
as a gift and I have never met
uh five girls in my son these people
these beautiful little Souls who have
the best work ethic of anybody I've ever
met in my life
Keeping Up with the Kardashians first
aired on E in 2007. nine spin-offs later
the family found a new TV home on Hulu
in 2022. how do you decide then okay
well this is old news this doesn't
matter or we keep this this is still
relevant hello babe yeah do you want to
shower with me really quick
I think Kim is really good at
um you know uh zeroing in on things like
that those kind of issues that might
seem stale and with that move the money
followed Chris and her kids are
reportedly splitting a nine figure
salary Hulu has been a dream it feels
grown and it feels like we've evolved
anything you change along the way the
chapters are beautiful this is exactly
where I'm supposed to be sitting and I
live my life like that
[Music]
I guess it's true what they say
everything happens for a reason oh for
sure I of course we can't wrap things up
without giving our girl Kendall some
love
just kind of chop up some cucumber it's
pretty easy there you go girl
be careful because I cut I nipped myself
the other day I don't know I'm kind of
scared there you go I definitely not a
good cutter so don't zoom in on me
I'm not professional whatsoever no she
is not that is The Chopping technique
that broke the internet and culminated
in Kendall's hilarious Halloween look
but Kendall may have outmeamed herself
with this Met Gala moment I need to
drink a water and I need to pee nobody
jokes Kendall we have the ice bucket
nobody judge me oh my God
[Applause]
remind me not to rent that limousine oh
she's a real one for that yeah all right
y'all that is it for us today catcher's
right here for a new episode of ETS the
download bye everybody
[Music]